hi everyone and welcome to NDC Oslo I
hope you had a great a great session
today that you have seen a lot of good
talks and you uh some of you who are
presenters ready for the uh NDC uh board
dinner which is a cruise dinner which is
going to be really really good so I'm
the last talk so hope that you'll have a
really good night tonight
all right so what I'm going to talk
about today is the common mistakes in EF
core and interestingly enough I started
this talk kind of a few years ago
because I was a little bit annoyed of
fixing the same things over and over
but later I really realized the reason
why I was so annoyed is because most of
these issues you know they don't have
much problems they're just you know a
little bit annoyance a little bit of
performance issues or maybe a couple of
bucks
but some of these issues cause people to
work over weekends scores projects to
fail on day one how many of you have
heard about government
websites going live and then going
offline because it didn't load uh didn't
handle the load
so some of the things that might have
happened that day are in here
so yeah you might want one I want to
remember some of them
and that's basically the motivation for
it is so that you don't get those
moments where it's like it work in
production it work in staging it worked
sorry not production it worked actually
did work in production it just once
people come in and start to use your
system and start adding data to your
database feels a thing starts to fall
over because it wasn't developed with
high volume data
all right
that out of the way I am Jane Kafka but
you can just call me JK I'm actually
originally from Slovenia quite close
from here but I live now in Australia so
in spite of being close by uh natively
a very long trip
you have lots of Socials I'm on Twitter
GitHub my blog then also LinkedIn I
organize quite a few events in Australia
and if you're interested about AI I also
am one of the hosts on the global AI the
podcast we actually just covered the
open AI team and it got dropped like two
three hours ago so you can learn more
about Open AI
and I am a dotnet core developer mostly
specialized in efco and I'm also an AI
MVP that works a lot with changept
ml.net and things like that
and this is something my company makes
me do is you can scan the QA code to get
this app and at the end when you scan
another QA code you can win some rewards
which I hear are pretty good
I can give you Q code at the end if you
want
all right so intro so I kind of
explained a little bit the motivation
behind of what I'm doing this talk
um but at the beginning I'm going to
show you things that will allow you to
replicate what I'm doing so I'm going to
show you some links I'm going to show
you what my machine is and all of that
stuff so you can just take the GitHub
code and try it for yourself so you can
see how different changes have impacts
then I'm going to move to seven deadly
sins those are the seven most deadliest
thing I have seen in EF core that
happened too frequently
and at the end I'll do a couple of mini
best practices
all right so
how many of you know more than four or
five different databases
all right just a few uh free hands but
you know the longer you work in the
industry you're starting to see that
there's a lot of databases popping up
SQL Server Cosmos DB progress SQL and
MySQL right
and we have lots of bunch of orems as a
result to handle all of these databases
so for instance you want to go uh SQL
server and then it's like ah no I want
to go to post postgres you can either
choose to write uh SDK specific code for
each of the databases and then you have
lots of issues migrating now in practice
as much as a lot of people say that you
move between databases
it doesn't happen frequently but when it
does
having oriums is really good because
they handle the abstraction between all
of these databases and now databases are
just popping up all the time uh so one
day your boss comes in and says hey
Cosmos DB is really cool let's go on
this and you're just like
okay
so this is why efco is great because it
kind of gives you the best balance
between features flexibility and
performance
and it's really good relational database
and it has built-in migrations database
scaffolding and other tools now if
anyone is doing immigration from
database first on.net framework might
know how useful is to have database
scaffolding because
take the database and then convert it in
code first
and then just continue on with the
built-in migrations it's awesome
and the thing here is efco basically
allows you to also switch databases
which is really cool
it still requires work to achieve that
but your business logic can remain the
same
and the part of this presentation is
basically how can we resolve some of the
issues with ef core now all of the stuff
that I have told you now is the reasons
why you want to go to EF core
but the next parts are going to be the
issues that people find and say why did
we go to EF cool there's so many issues
and stuff like that and then you just
look at the code and you're like you
know what the issue is not really if
core it's how you structured your query
so I want to show that
and when I'm going to show you all of
that I want to show you that you can
actually also simplify your code by
doing best practices
and I'm going to give you benchmarks for
the code that's written and some with
the tests
and I'm going to show you a few horror
stories without mentioning any names
or give any scenarios that could link to
them
all right so this one really quick The
Benchmark tools so the first couple of
tests are going to be via benchmark.net
this is to show you the impact on memory
consumption and time for a single
execution the first two make sense to do
then for the rest of them there's not
really that much of a difference so I
just skip them
and then the bombandia is the the tool
that I used for all all of them and what
this one does it allows me to use a
simple command line to hit for instance
an API 20 Frets
consistently for say 60 seconds and then
I can see how many requests have I
handled now this is not technically load
test it's just you know gently loading
up requests it doesn't try to overwhelm
the service
uh but it gives you an idea how your
website will work how that endpoint will
work when you start getting more loads
because in one example you're seeing ah
it's only 3.5 times slower
and then in another test you'll say oh
wait this is a lot more than just 3.5
times uh slower
I'll get to that one
and just in case you want to verify my
timings
uh dot Net 7 with ef core 7 and ryzen 9.
with 32 gigs of RAM and just putting
this there in case somebody wants to
play this over this around at home
the test data is 7 million uh sales it's
very simple database we have 500
products 20 employees and 20 000
customers I intentionally picked a very
simple database because this kind of
database shouldn't give you much
performance issue or much issue at all
but you can get to big troubles if you
write really terrible SQL statements oh
sorry link statements
all right not to the fun part seven
deadly sins
so the first one uh some of you may know
what happened here if you have I
variable and you cast it to I enumerable
then we have S Note tracking
explicit joins
getting all the columns from the
database
and we have no paginations
uh non-cancedable queries and
inefficient updates or deletes
and when you hit all of their seven how
many of you uh have asked yourself in
your mind how bad can it be
one advice never ask that question
there's no good answer to it
so let's go with iclarable to I
enormable
so we have this one we have two list dot
count right
um
and then we have this one we are taking
the sales we're putting into I I
numerable uh variable and then we count
it
and then we have a method that returns a
ineurable list
and then basically we count this
does anyone think these things are
different
well they're all the same
and they're all the same because if you
do to list you get all the entire
database if you cast it into I
enumerable
that's almost like you're doing two
lists you're getting all of the data all
of the sales from the database and what
is the most common issue that I see is
that
developers want to be good they want to
be abstract and then they say you know
what I'm not going to do the the type
that's
uh say the DB set that the sales return
or I crab I'll do I innumerable because
you know it's the highest one that you
can do is the highest one uh in terms of
type compatibility right they're trying
to be a good developer
but in this particular case this is
really bad
in all of the other cases I enormous
actually good
so what happens here is we're making an
HTTP request
uh here we have done below uh the EIN
number ball sales DB context dot sales
and what happens is when we are trying
to evaluate uh the query the
um
the efco query
it will only evaluate to the point where
we hit the casting to I enumerable well
we do two lists so what we end up with
is is Select stuff from sales
and that means that it literally don't
launch the entire database
and then as you've seen in the code we
just count them so it just the looks at
the number how big the list is
and then dumps all of the results
into garbage collector we never used any
of the data that we received from SQL
Server
so here
The Simple Solution is to use I variable
when you return in methods
now this is the simple part let's go to
the fun part of ah so here
if you use icon variable uh you
basically the entire statements gets
translated
and then you have select count stuff
but you know it's not interesting to
just see uh okay just avoid I
innumerable I was just like you know I
really want to burn that in everyone's
mind so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to ask myself how bad can it be if
you don't do that
ah and yeah
remember this slide I credible is in EF
core is not the same as I innovable
so why is this bad and how bad it can be
how about two gigabytes memory
consumption
does that sound bad enough
then okay it's 64 times faster actually
64. there's two ah so this one ratio
this one is uh average whereas this one
is mean
so basically it means that most of the
queries were somewhat fast
um but you know at some point it just
tipped over and everything was slow
but that's not the fun part what if we
load test this
you know here we have 3.5 times faster
in here 64 times faster these are just
numbers right what if we have lots of
users using with this feature well what
happens is that the average response is
33 seconds
just to get count of sales
yeah imagine that
it takes 128 milliseconds if you just do
the right query
so now this is 260 times faster
big numbers
since he see here how much impact and
I'm innumerable in the wrong place can
uh can make so this is if you remember
anything remember this you'll make my
life easier
all right so the next one is astronaut
tracking and this one what does is it
allows a query
which is by default uh trackable that
means that if you change it and you do
save changes
uh it basically will know okay this
entity has changed this property so in
the database we need to change this
round for this column
and you know if you need that that's
awesome and you should use it
but when you don't
um what you can do is use dot as not
tracking
now I'm putting here warnings because
some people warn me
don't tell them because then they will
use it and then no changes will happen
in a database
so here I am saying for the third time
no changes will be made in the database
if you use S Note tracking
all right so what happens behind the
scenes uh so when we generate uh queries
um we send the query uh on efco we send
the query the SQL Server we get back the
data we pass the data and map this is
all done behind the scenes but there's
an extra step to it we are doing uh EF
core uh tracking behind the scenes
basically it hides some data that you
cannot see directly in your code to know
how your entities are being changed and
then you get back results in the code
where you can use it
so here
any changes that you do against the
entities that you get back this way will
be captured by save changes by DDP
context save changes
now if you do asthma tracking
this step is skipped
now why this is important it's not just
because it's one it won't be tracked the
other thing is it can use significantly
less memory in my test it happens that
it you used four times less memory what
they realized is this a very
wide range of performance gains or
memory consumption gains depending on
the query
uh so Yuma us can
um
sorry you might get different results
uh also it's faster
now the thing here to
um keep in mind is uh you might does
anyone know Nick chapsis
all right you might have seen his video
about
um
efco performance and he says well don't
use uh astronaut tracking because it
doesn't give you any benefits what I
realized is that they might actually be
differences between the database
providers so in his test he actually
didn't get any major differences when he
used as not tracking but on SQL Server I
got pretty major differences so keep
that in mind as well so if you use this
for performance reasons make performance
measurements before you're like yeah
just use it everywhere
um yeah
so timings wise
we have a full times high speed when we
Lo when we test on the load so basically
um the reason why I'm focusing so much
on the speed here is I'm dealing with
applications
that needs the process a lot of data
they need to also process a lot of
requests and the longer you take to
process things for Unnecessary reasons
uh the fewer requests you can process
the more likelihood is that your service
that's to get overloaded and toppled and
Asthma tracking is a like a very easy
thing to add especially if we know that
the dot is not going to change with it
gives you a little bit more buffer
between you know your server working
fine and yes a server just exploding
because it just getting too many
requests to process
and also very important this mostly
impacts the botnet side so if your.net
site is running really hot you can
alleviate a little bit on the.net side
it doesn't have any impact on the SQL
server side
another really uh
annoying thing for me is but include the
reason for it is a lot of people like to
dot include
and then they forget to remove them and
no longer need it and they're thinking
oh yeah if it's no longer needed it's
not going to cry by uh by that doctor
right it's just not going to include
join well it turns out even if you do
dot select to map your data
it will still do the dot include even if
you use it nowhere
so it will do the joins and if you know
SQL server or SQL in general joins are
one of the more expensive operations you
can do
so the way the way to go around that is
actually using implicit joins
so what you can do is instead of doing
uh like here where I have a DOT include
and I'm including the sales person you
can instead just make a select statement
where we directly use those tables as
properties
what happens here is it will implicitly
include whatever we're adding into
select
therefore if we remove these two lines
there won't be any join statement
and this basically alleviates you from
every uh from checking every time if
somebody forgot to remove the included
statement
and I'm not sure how how many code
accounts you have seen we have one
master method where it has literally a
hundred lines of includes and I'm just
like
why
I I understand
why would you want to do that if you
don't have any performance and you know
if that doesn't literally cause your
database just panicking saying wait I
need to connect everything with
everything
um
but still
why
and to show you the impact here
it's 2.5 times faster and in the end of
the day
you're getting exactly the same result
and if you look back in the code
you're actually more clearer what you
want
now you might hide this code in you know
a mapping Library so it might not be as
abundantly clear you might need to jump
to the mapping code
but still it's very clear this is the
dot I want just get me that
and you're getting a free performance
out of that
and talking about mapping and fetching
data pagination is one of really major
problems that they have seen especially
on projects where you have developers
that are not used to deal with really
large data like if you're dealing with
systems that deals with licensing you
have like you could potentially have
thousands of licenses per product
and all of the sudden when you try to
load those licenses up
um you know it quickly comes from oh
yeah on production for two weeks it
worked everything fine then people start
purchasing one product and when you try
to click that product it just the whole
system freezes up
um that actually happened
it's like I clicked that product
everything looks fine click that product
it's a little bit slow but everything
you're fine I click that product and all
of the sudden nobody can access the
website anymore
it's like it feels like almost that that
product is cursed but what end up
happening is almost the same mistake as
at the beginning where we had
um essentially dot count on the entire
table download the entire table and Dot
count
a little bit less bad but still similar
and what the most common code that I
have seen on how they're trying to do
pagination is this so one they do is
they actually they're doing correctly at
the beginning you know you do the uh way
close you're trying to add whatever you
need in the query
but then they're getting all of the
results and I was like why are they
trying to get all of the results before
they do pagination all of that stuff
it turns out they don't know how to get
the count
from the database
for the filter so they first get all of
the data
then they get the count and then in
memory they filter it down and what
usually happens is like well it's good
enough you know if you try to fix this
is you know
there's no performance issues as far as
we can tell
um but then the data starting to
increase and all of the sudden there are
issues
oh yeah here's the in-memory uh
pigeonation
so what you should really do is
essentially
use Ike variables so you can reuse the
query more than once do whatever you
need to do
and then on that query on that I
credible he did a DOT count
and later on that same query you apply
take a Skip and take so that will do the
pagination and then you get all of the
data now you'll be saying hey Janke
you're now doing two requests isn't that
slower than one
well you would think so but the thing is
this dot count
in SQL Server is surprisingly fast
a lot faster usually than getting more
than one page of data
so that's that's the performance hit I'm
more than happy to take because that's
like a few milliseconds
um because if this thing goes wrong
we're talking about seconds or even
minutes of performance penalties
so yeah this is a lot faster
I'll we're just a little bit and seeing
some people are taking a picture
all right so
what's the damage here
well we have 1.3 seconds
that doesn't tell us a lot
um 7 75 milliseconds if you do per
generation which is 18 times faster and
just keep in mind in all of these cases
we're returning exactly the same thing
to the client there's no changes we we
only change how we execute the query
and regaining insane amount of
performance gain also one thing that I
forgot to mention at at the beginning
and uh here is
from the first first case onwards I
stopped querying 7 million databases
because when I did the bad cases on
seven million cases my machine was
unresponsive for 10 minutes and then I
was just like
cool I have really awesome numbers to
show and comparison
but then I also realized that I won't be
able to reuse my machine for 10 minutes
so all of the data that all of the tests
that I'm showing you have reduced data
set I think it's uh 700 000 hours a
million just to give you a perspective
of how bad things can get I literally
had to reduce the number of set
otherwise my computer was unusable
but in all of the good cases there was
no at no time more than five seconds
that my computer was unresponsive
so that's how major of a difference can
make from you know
doing a very horrible thing and very
good thing in EF core
all right
talking about horrible things and things
uh not stopping
non-cancelablequarius it's almost like I
knew this this light is coming
um so this is a very interesting topic
for anyone who don't know what the
cancellation token is
how many of you oh actually let me
reverse the question how many of you
know cancellation token
okay we have a pretty a good number of
people
um about three quarters so how many of
you are using cancellation tokens
on efco queries
okay maybe a quarter for the room
uh okay so this this one might come as a
surprise for some
so
let's say you don't use cancellation
token on queries what's the problem
well let's start simple let's start with
HTTP request uh doing some things then
you make an EF core query and you know
how you have some of those queries that
are very complicated but you can't do
anything about it it's you know if it's
going to take 30 seconds it's going to
take 50 seconds it's just not much you
can do about it and you know it might be
a use case with that's fine the user can
wait
but what happens if the user canceled
that request that HTTP request
well if you don't have a cancellation
token that thing still runs
for 30 seconds
now what happens if somebody starts to
spam F5
yeah you might guess that nothing good
so this is why you want to use
cancellation token and I'll get to Juicy
numbers shortly
basically what you want to do is when
you're using web API and if anyone is
trapped with.net framework you can do
that as well
I know that unfortunately
so when you're doing cancellation token
you can apply to to list async and that
will hook up to the cancellation token
that is for that HTTP request so when
then HTTP request gets canceled it will
also get canceled on the EF core
but there is a little bit more magic to
it because if we look back to the same
example we have the HTTP request he of
course sends the SQL to SQL server and
SQL servers that's the process that
request
when we do cancellation requests it's
not just that dotnet star assess ah okay
I don't need to process this thing what
also happens is that request gets pushed
to SQL server and SQL Server is like oh
you don't need that anymore fine I'll
stop
so what happens is they both stop
say if somebody is spamming uh F5 now
this is going to be a bit of overhead
but generally speaking things stop
and you won't overload the system
because of that
so what happens is here I intentionally
picked a query that will basically took
longer than the timeout that that I put
so I put a timeout in one second and I
basically did a query that literally
downloaded 7 million actually I think I
did reduce the 2 million because I
actually wanted to use my computer
anyways the point is
um
I used a query that takes about two
seconds
and what happened is this so at the end
the latency ended up being 10 seconds
per request on average which is pretty
bad
uh and that's without cancellation
tokens when I use cancellation tokens in
only half the five seconds so it wasn't
like it was you know just two seconds or
just one seconds
the system get got overloaded
and with overloading it means that the
code actually starts to slow down in
terms of execution and that also meant
that cancellation token didn't quite
came as fast as they should go to
the.net part as well as SQL Server now
here what we're talking about is trying
intentionally overloading the system
to test how well this works
but all despite all of that it got two
times faster
and the thing about this is this the
cancellation one with the consension
token it took about 40 seconds to get
back responsive and this is by me trying
to overload the machine
when uh when I didn't have cancellation
token I couldn't move the mouse
for 10 minutes
it was keep churning and churning and
churning and I had to wait for every
single thing to be protest until the
machine is even ready for me to move the
mouse
so that's how bad it got and yes this is
why I want to have cancellation tokens
and this is the easiest way if you don't
Implement cancellation tokens how you
can DDOS a machine in fact you wouldn't
even need to DDOS them if this stage is
just the denial service just you know
you just Hammer F5 really quickly
that that would be the uh denial of
service for this kind of uh endpoint
just hitting F5
all right now the last sin is the
inefficient update uh Slash delete
now before EF course seven
this one was a bit harder to fix
but with ef core 7 this one is now a lot
easier to fix
so the problem with updating in EF core
some of you may know is
you need to get data as tracking
and then you need to do the changes
basically it means that you always have
to make a select statement a select SQL
statement and then update uh the thing
or delete them right
so it's quite inefficient especially if
you need to update 7 million records
that can take a long time remember that
to list dot count about that amount of
time
so instead now here I just did for fun
uh changing first name to last name
um just for fun
here we have a simple uh process of
changing first name and last name and
what we have to do is get all of the
people then we go to for each Loop and
then what we do is swap those properties
around
you can do whatever else you want to do
uh one common uh thing that's happening
when we're talking about really large
data is basically just flipping a zero
to a one feature talk link for instance
for all of the users you want to enable
a feature or for instance your
processing data and then you say I
processed all of the data up to that
point and historically EF core didn't
have a good way of dealing with that
problem uh you end up using raw SQL
instead if you um if you had to deal
with big data because any other way it
just wasn't acceptable
um
but also you have here SQL statement as
well for each of the
um each of the
employees we change there's a separate
SQL statement so if you have 7 million
of records that means you'll have 7
million update statements and that thing
can grow really really big
so instead what you can do is you can
actually just execute updates directly
on SQL Server so what I'm doing here is
I'm just saying
um for the uh for the employees uh table
uh execute this update and let me see I
and sap the property first default so
first name to be last name now here
instead of this loss B dot last name you
can just use a concrete number or
concrete string or whatever you want to
set this
property by but I'm showing this example
as
setting an actual column because that's
the common thing that happens in those
bulk updates is you want to update the
existing
column to be updated say you add an
additional thing
or you want to add a number or swap say
um if it's true you want to put it that
falls or fall if it's false you're
trying to put into true and for that
those kind of Logics in EF core you need
to get the data from the database you
couldn't just uh do this simply and now
you have all of the tools to do that
whether it's a fixed data you get
or if you need to reuse the data that
the column supplies you
ah and also the SQL upnet is like really
thin
like you have only one statement which
is awesome
so what happens here
is of course we're getting better
performance
which is great but one thing that is uh
very important here is
um if you want to use astronaut tracking
for instance you don't want to
um you don't want to have trackable
entities you want to be in control
when and how the dot is updated in the
database this gives you not the tools to
do this so basically what you can do is
you can choose that all of the currency
do are non-trackable they're all of the
currency do don't impact safe changes
because you want to be in control
and then if you have a very complicated
case where you need to you know very
complicated catered uh relational
structure then you choose to have it
tracking because one of the things that
I'm looking into is
can we fully control of what goes from
the SQL server not the mesh and what
goes into SQL Server database
and this is for the first time this
actually gives us that control
now if if you um just thinking about
okay how do I use this I'm I haven't
been doing a lot of design patents and
stuff like that the important thing here
to note is just
you can just say update me this record
and update this property to that
property without worrying about anything
all right mini best practices
seven deadly sins those are one of the
worst things that I've seen in uh in
production
now there's some honorable mentions
first
so first off
have anyone seen uh a developer trying
to download the entire database just to
see if there's any data
I've seen this more times than um I'm
willing to admit
just use dot any please
I don't want to see this anymore
you have literally here I actually
looked at this code for one hour and I
was just like
I was trying to get into that mindset
and I was just like they probably just
don't know what they did here it's all
good let's move on
then what we have here is this one is
something that I'm just like okay I
totally get uh where uh with the issues
here
so what happens here is
we're trying to apply a conditional
filter
and what's with a lot of developers
happens is either they're trying to do
over complicated weight loss because
they don't know they can just store the
query into variable and then just you
know do just multiple break clauses and
modified the query over time so they're
trying to make that one big bang query
and get all of the data and everything
that they couldn't fit in they're trying
to just process it later in memory
so instead of doing that
you can
just store your query into an i query
ball and process as you go see for
instance over here we have cell ID if
it's not null we add an additional
weight loss
if it's not that's fine we skip it and
then at the end we do two lists
so this is one thing that a lot of
people didn't know is
you can do that
and a really nice site effect of this is
that if sales sell ID is null
um basically the SQL Server is
non-divisive it's not that weird thing
where you dot where and then is if Cell
ID is not now
then filtered by ID otherwise just
ignore this
um and then if you have multiple
optional statements like this the whole
query becomes so unreadable because then
you need to think about okay uh why is
this ah okay this is optional what about
this one this line uh okay this one
doesn't look it's option ah no it is
optional here at the very end it just
becomes really hard to read this
and this is very easy to read I mean it
does expand a little bit in verticality
but this is very simple code to read so
please don't over complicate their
Clauses you can just you know string
them slowly
now next one
how many of you know about DB context
Paul
very few hands Maybe
seven okay
uh
so DB context pool
good thing that I added so what DB
context pool allows you to do is how
many of you actually know about hdb
context poll
also very few hands okay we need to talk
about that
um okay so uh let me just explain the
xyzpool in.net if it comes from the
Microsoft team that means that whatever
that thing is it's going to be reused if
used correctly
what that means in this particular case
is when you're trying to get the big
context
and you add DB context pool it will try
to recycle an existing one and the way
it's going to recycle is it will keep
the connection to the SQL Server so it's
not going to be constantly closing and
opening the database connection which if
some some of the SQL Server expert might
know that connection can linger for a
little bit it can take a bit time to
close down
if you overwhelm the SQL Server all of
the sudden you can come to situations
especially if you're not the only
application using next signal server
that all of the sudden there's no
connections
to that SQL Server all of the sudden SQL
Server says hey I have already too many
connections open and then you look at
how many connections are used you
realize actually not many
and that's because they're still closing
down
so that improves that thing and as a
side effect you also have better
performance and memory uh usage because
it doesn't have to constantly initialize
and Destroy DB context a pool
but the important reason why I'm adding
this is because of resiliency so if
somebody is spamming F5
just this adding pool at the end of DB
context in the um in the dependence
injection
will improve your chance of your of your
application being responsive
it will allow your application to more
gracefully handle that load just adding
these four letters
there's a little catch here all there
if you're using
um depends injections on the DB context
well-being DB context pool
you will have to rethink a little bit
how you add that
dependency because the DB context pool
is recycled
one easy way to do this is to just use
an interface
in your Di and then just manually inject
your dependencies when you instantiate
the DB context
that's the easiest way to do it but just
keep in mind
your DB context is no longer
um your DB contest has to be stateless
because it's going to be reused
another really cool thing
tag width so what time grid does and you
should append it to as many queries as
you can
is it adds a comment to the SQL commands
that gets generated and the reason why
this is really cool is if you have a
query that is unusually bad
and all you see is that huge jumble of
SQL and you're like okay uh we use this
table in that that thing and that and
that column is like okay that could be
any of these queries over here we don't
know which one this SQL statement uh
reflects to but if you use stag width
you can just look at the uh the SQL
statement and it says Ah Yeah on the top
we have the common you can just copy
that Ctrl shift F and find exactly with
that link statement is now in before EF
core 3.1 uh you had problems with
queries was split it
uh so you wouldn't sometimes multiple
queries actually originated from the
same link statement and in fact you can
still do that but it's explicit you can
do a split uh query
this tag width is included for both of
the both of the SQL generated code
so when you try to copy it and you see
uh okay I have two queries with the same
tag but in the code just only one you
now know that
that's a link statement has been split
into two queries
and that saves a lot of debugging trust
me
and last bearness facts
GPT
so if you want to use chant GPT to
basically help you generate your queries
or try to explain your queries and
things like that you can just say you on
efco Expert and write whatever think you
want you can do DB context you can just
paste the code if it's too long just
remove some lines you can just paste the
entities there
if it's too many just remove the ones
that are not used and even return types
if you want to return something specific
now you might notice that the also set
and clean code developer uh because what
I notice is if we don't do that some of
the code that you get bad about back is
pretty terrible
it works
but it's terrible
so that's why this is the secret sauce
clink uh clean code developer
now I have a very a lot better querying
so if anyone is interested I can share
that one for you but it's a lot bigger
and I also have one where you describe
code AS mantras and somehow is better
than doing strict rules
but yeah
he's a result result of one of the
queries so
we have the UR efco expert and clean
code developer get all employee details
for each get statistics on how many
products they sold how much they earned
and list of sales they did all paginated
now with all of the stuff that you have
seen today you probably will be able to
do a pretty good query on your first
maybe second try
but JJ fatigue gun is pretty good on its
first try and just took a few seconds to
do it
um so yeah this this is actually pretty
good uh query
um
if I would send this in a pull request
I'll probably just say yeah looks good
maybe add attack width
um there is no s tracking here so maybe
add that considering we're just
returning all of the data and probably
not changing
you probably won't do updates on a
tracked on a paginated
query
so this is pretty good
not that I remembered
how many of you know that when you do
select statement that query is no longer
has no tracking
we have one hand
amazing
so yes technically speaking
sorry
yeah you can ask a question
ah yes uh so one of the good points is
that if
um but
one of the good points is that we can
get
exactly as much data as we need
now another the reason why I personally
still use S Note tracking even though
the technically slack does that for me
is if instance here we have product name
and we add an additional line where we
say product equal s dot product
so we're taking the whole property of
product
that property is technically tracked
so
you have now introduced a property
that's
like a lot of developers didn't know
that that actually is tracked
that is not tracked and if we
accidentally change that because you
think oh yeah it's just a copy from the
database it's as not tracking because of
the select and then you do save changes
you might have inadvertently changed a
data just because you thought that was
not tracking and if you add at the
beginning as not tracking
um I would need to double check that but
I think everything you access from it uh
everything you do in the select
statement is not tracked this is why I
do that despite select statement or
editing that a quick question then and
then we'll continue
the client
oh okay
um uh sorry about that yeah
so what you were saying is if there's
anything in the select statement that
cannot be
recognized in
EF chord 2.2
backwards and I think still in 3.1 it
did get you all of the data I as far as
I checked the last time e of course
seven it fills the query because it
cannot be evaluated
uh on the SQL server or it is successful
provide that that it can only fetch that
specific data but I think there is one
uh catch to this that there is one use
case where it actually downloads the uh
the entire
one row but I don't think it tries to
download the entire database but this is
very uh
very specific use case but uh thanks for
that
um yes as no tracking can be sometimes
very complicated and what you put in
select statements especially if you're
trying to use something that is not
supported on SQL Server can give you
some unexpected results
but from ef ef Core 5 they try to
minimize those impacts instead of uh you
know having very unexpected results
your performance going down the toilet
um
it basically just tells you hey I cannot
execute that on SQL Server
all right
I promise this at the last two slides
with content
so then we can go for a nice dinner
before we end
I want to just touch really quickly on
how many people know what premature
optimization is
we have a few hands okay
um so one important thing to know about
this is essentially
if you worry about some of these things
being premature optimization with
spending too much time or fixing up this
kind of things generally speaking if he
following good practices for the given
scenarios
that's not premature optimization you
should likely do that
and when you have a method say an
endpoint for instance that is expected
to have high load
and you don't have time to do
performance improvements you should talk
to your product owner and say hey we
either add this to acceptance criteria
or we add the new PBI this is a high
load endpoint it has to be dealt with it
has to be fast
and lastly from uh from that section is
um when you know that something already
causes a performance issues uh either it
could be Memory it could be time or it
could be anything else
to try to make a technical debt out of
it create a PBI or issue or task in your
systems put them into backlog make sure
that you address them before you make a
major deployment
and write that in the code make a
comment linking back to that issue
and this is very important because this
is how you're getting those production
issues where everyone is up awake on
Saturday night trying to figure out
what's wrong
and lastly what you should not do
we'll fix it later
with no actions
then just say fix it later as I said
before create the technical that put it
on backlog and mark the code with a
comment we'll fix this later
here's the issue link it to that issue
the reason for it is if things go bad on
on the day that you release and everyone
is like we have no idea what's going on
this is the first place you should look
if it's performance issue if your
service just not responding and see what
you have missed because there's a good
chance there's something you have
forgotten about it and now you know
where it is
and another thing a lot of developers
tell me ah
if I fix this it's premature
optimization and now look at the code
it's like mate this is bad code
don't use premature optimization as a
bad excuse for bad God
in worst case scenario you create a
tactical dad but you know you probably
shouldn't want to leave Matt code in
your codes
so yeah please don't use that as an
excuse
all right so here are the resources the
first thing is where you can try out all
of the examples I did it did you can do
the benchmarks yourself the second one
is Microsoft resources for EF core now
there is a section for performance
when I started this talk most of the the
stuff that I was talking about today
were not in it today most of the stuff
is in it and I'm super proud of
Microsoft to add that the problem is
nobody read those
so if you want to learn more go to that
page it's awesome
also as ssw we have ssw rules so you can
check our page about rules for Entity
framework and Link only to do some
updates on it and also Nick chapsis has
a pretty good uh videos on EF core and
you know lots of different things
actually got a bit of inspiration from
him to do this Benchmark things to
actually show you the impact that the
code does because I think that just hits
harder and basically you're thinking
twice before you're leaving a bad
Coating in your Repository
just leave for five more seconds
so how many of you have learned
something new today
a lot that's like 90 percent
almost the entire room awesome
it's a key takeaways are only uh I have
limited myself to only free
so that you can remember them
I memorable is very very dangerous
you might see something in the EF code
Microsoft documentation where it shows
you something in normal use it only if
you understand why it's fast
otherwise don't use I need
and Asthma tracking can give you a
really good performance improvements for
almost no impact but make sure that you
understand that anything that you'll do
with that data will not be modified in
the database
and the last one
I hope you've seen that we got from one
code that you know fetches some thought
and then counts and then another code
that just includes a table and you don't
know why it included that table to a
code that actually tells you what's
going on
and become more performant it was
simpler to read and it did exactly what
you wanted
see sometimes you can have the cake and
eat it
you just need to know how
and last part if you want I'll keep this
slide at the end you can come to me and
scan it you can win some good prizes
you can find the presentation of the net
I can give you the link later
thanks
[Applause]